t comment vont les ukrainiens comme on
vend les habitants de kiev c'est une
ville fantôme il neige conditions très
compliquées pour les gens qui survivent
ici conditions très compliquées pour la
résistance qui s'organise mais qui est
fatigué nous avons pu avec georgette bec
rencontré le président zelensky dans un
endroit fortifier un bunker un endroit
tenu secret beaucoup de précautions de
sécurité pour voter ce président qui
lui-même nous a dit qu'il était fatigué
à l'image de tous les ukrainiens à
l'image de cette résistance qui
s'organise mais les conditions sont
difficiles et on voit bien encore une
fois pour être avoir été hier soir à la
tombée de la nuit sur ce front nord
ouest dans les villes de dire pin
notamment où se concentre cette
offensive est bien que là les tirs
d'artillerie sont redoublé il y a une
puissance de feu une capacité de feu
extrêmement importante les russes ne ne
désarment pas et on est vraiment entré
dans cette phase où on va arriver ici à
un siège donc le la l'ambiance n'est pas
évidemment à l'optimiste il ya sept des
tops détermination qui est assez
saisissante et incroyable la part de la
population quel que soit l'âge la
génération les hommes ou des femmes les
gens qui sont ici sont là pour rester
pour résister mais le rouleau
compresseur russe est en train de fondre
sur cette ville et on sait en tout cas
dans des conditions en fait encore une
fois très difficile qu'il va y avoir
c'est une très très longue guerre on est
parti ici pour des mois de confrontation
militaire entre les ukrainiens et le
l'envahisseur russe